I'm going you are you letting you oh you
know to you what I don't know what's up
everybody welcome back to tipping case
today I'm gonna be testing TIF on her
Chinese if she's been learning but I
just only learned the colors in a couple
phrases and the numbers not really that
or anything but I'm gonna be testing
Hugo and Spanish also because you took
Spanish in high school so you know you
know good amount of Spanish so we're
gonna be testing each other and see if
we know what the word means let's do it
gene canto vs. team Spanish no Chi who
goes first
hey paper scissors first word yes yes it
does mean okay okay oh my god why is
that so hard right don't you put like
easy stuff I give you some easy stuff
new beginning
okay oh ha you know what when I was
picking these uh words I was trying to
make sure that the words I picked don't
sound like English like they're English
English equivalent because usually a lot
of Spanish words sound like English
words so I was trying to pick words that
don't sound like what they are okay I
want smart English that's where I don't
have that problem cuz I'm its Chinese
it's not Latin based at all okay okay oh
it's like the sure yeah cuz if they see
an English you might give it away
okay yo so nabu happen across that
wasn't the noun or the verb or the
adjective I don't even know
I don't want you taking all this talking
about now lovers you know what that
means I thought I could do some context
clues and that doesn't help at all
AG Yu jae-ha
to juice no yeah it's a needle once I'll
say it is so the sentence let's I use a
needle to soak that's not even close to
into English at all you're supposed to
start easy and then we get harder that
there's something I think there's
something you might know but I didn't
put them in order of like either you're
not so well this is a game show you
designed it poorly sorry my turn I give
you a courtesy
Nate oh why don't you just skip it
obviously I know that one okay fine
next one Langley Langley is it something
about a girl make a pretty girl yeah
pretty girl pretty girl
hey okay I see how it is I might have to
add in a few more advanced word yeah no
you should cuz I don't know how much
Spanish you know what's up I was trying
really hard to not give you like super
easy one you ready for the next one
yeah go ahead lay it lay it on me I'm
gonna just modify this as we go maybe
you know this one it's what I've been to
that ego I'm bad that's I do
I've been save a do is that a like it's
a place you focus establishment of some
sort you know sounds like one I thought
you would know that it would figure this
would be maybe like Windows beginner
words nosotros vivimos
I love it
but uh but uh yeah a library no it
sounds like a place the beginning of
this word sounds like the English
version of what this is okay they say
daddio bed set ABC Aereo so what is the
area okay next one going back to my
number ones I modified it so much so
much so much so much I use it incentive
uh uh I somewhat well you just help me
like we can oh my goodness old I some oh
I
SiC I'm a doctor I'm going to be suffer
your clue you look like a glove that it
the word was bitten so much I get I
guess it could be out of the one I don't
know
so what was your sentence with Oh ought
I something that means I'm wearing a
glove
yeah if you know we're no more handsome
okay but if you knew certain words like
so it means hand what is song in mind
the bunnies are hand saw that's the next
batch of words empowering the body parts
Tasi to advance for you know alright
next word might be yo my deal might be
of human sense you're tangled you chose
every mentor see you know this it's my
video okay that's too long ah there's
other vocabularies in that's and it's
that kind of overpower the one we're
talking about how do you use this thing
for something yeah and a RT i ll oh my
feel tomatillo it's a pepper
isn't that a pepper time with you agree
in the green tomato yeah
martinis cousin yeah I don't know hammer
a hammer might videos I have my deal
hammer the first sentence I told you was
I have a toolbox and one of my tools a
hammer and I'm like oh that's way too
long
yeah I could even decipher where Mike
must do is no sense I'm worried we're
gonna happen
ready by its local local local go you
call your dad low down low me honestly I
don't even know how to decipher these
words I I learned I didn't learn Chinese
like officially I learned it
phonetically from hearing it so in order
to do it like oh oh oh what do you say I
don't know
I give up tell me local it's me you
would like you me to meet you too me too
you yeah no does that mean me to you
what am I to you
husband yeah
my husband is such acute I'm pretty sure
you know this one so no idea I don't
know that the son of or yeah mmm
Santa or Santa Claus okay here's a clue
Jotham all who go they sign now audience
it's a fruit or it has juice does juice
come from this thing or you put juice
inside this thing I heard who go yeah
Google this I know
juice of this thing yeah oh okay all
right the fruit or could be it's a it's
a food it's liquid inside ah expansion
is so hard
onion are you saying my name is Betty
cantaloupe
that means I'm close and who means I'm
close close with the letter O letter
what's another food that starts in the
center of the fruit oh man they are I
think Anthony audience ah
he likes cheese no yeah I don't know
carrot
there's no juicing carrots carrots juice
oh yeah there's traffic oh this is the
final one fighting Gow fun is so many
things it's how fun it's like noodles
what else is fun I'm blinking right now
me too we had fun about fun go yeah I've
heard of go you've heard this term
before it's a chicken
no no that's guy oh yeah okay funny guy
this is something you learned actually
when we went to Hong Kong or actually
maybe when you went to send Alice to
visit my family it's a very practical
term now isn't it oh boy
Oh fun now is it to go eat is it I'm
hungry is it are you hungry
give me more clothes I give you a ton
this is all I'm gonna say Jesus at
nighttime good night
goodnight oh my gosh have you say
goodnight I'm blinking no Joe tell Joe
tell Joe to put the word in question fun
round go
I'll tell you if I'm tired sleep yeah
I'd love to say like the thing you do
right after you say Joe oh uh us letting
go so when do you when do we do that
like how do we say it we say good sleep
or whatever you say oh I [ __ ] no fun
gone I just say I'm tired I'm
emotionally I don't know it's just I
learned it phonetically and that's how I
hear people use it in movies and my
parents ease of that way so fun yet -
little fishes no Pistons no remember it
doesn't sound like the English yeah I
know I know
man me me think that took me forever to
coma that thing - I know it's hard
in English you know you told me in a
common sign this as those like - a have
such a fake American accent when I speak
Chinese now in the system yes Bongo
neither too much of a clue or even get
it right away that's a clue no I was
gonna say the word after that maybe this
thing is Bongo Bongo a nice time yes
mascara mascara makeup eyeshadow blush
lipstick wedding makeup powder your
Bongo your boom-boom mascara and
- makeup bag no I put my mascara in
something yeah well it's not really in
on the vanity table upstairs and that's
where you put it though I don't know you
got to put in your purse and make a
bagger on top of the whatever miss era
on that's what I said I put my Skara on
eyelashes I so got that one yeah it
sounds like it could be a type of person
here is Tanya okay this one you should
know dupa dupa oh oh I think you know
this go to Python I said what is me babe
fried pork chop something
joopa it's cheese maybe is it melted
cheese is it o is Japan beat yeah I
think you're overthinking it now tomato
is it to make a note of interior
thinking - no good - Papa yes fun right
mm-hmm move trip out fine you know what
that is right say it in English I don't
know a rice baked dish tomato pork chop
I don't know like what what are you
really calling spinach big part up okay
got a big pork chops like the main
ingredient you did but you said it like
with like other words like in a rose
you're like I wasn't your efficient
yes you're just like glazing over the
word but yes porkchop Oh two pies not
hmm well speaking of food here that's a
clue this is all yes I like food because
I can I think you know this one I can
guess miss Melly's get one right no but
you got one right right oh yeah cuz I
helped you anyway this one before it is
[ __ ] yet rich yeah hungry channel the
menus of all the Mexican restaurants
ever been to oh yeah your brother ever
went to Mexico your brother-in-law he
was making crispy yes or no like oh yes
Diaz and then from that day on because
the ads was embedded my brain has ribs
good job baby all right thanks Chum oh
that's not bad for no I picked this one
cuz it's so hard to say to the lot of a
lot of ABC's a lot of American for
Chinese people they'll say Chung learn I
don't know it's I can't even do that
it's hard oh oh oh oh you told them oh
these are angry money yeah these are
good sense it's like a cause-and-effect
kind of thing I'm saying is I don't even
know how to construct sentences in
Chinese I give up
[Music]
how do you say Oh gotcha
that's all you now say oh yeah no math
no oh no I
Ravi yeah yeah Rodya Rodya
really gay oh no like another Spanish
word we just use mascara it was one of
the words that you you were praising
about how you knew this guy knows what
is the best on yours like wispy yet yes
Ravi Yakko see ya brisket because rib
right yeah yes yes is the leg closed the
thigh Laurel at the azomite doesn't like
you use it to step on the road road yes
no okay more close between the thigh in
the ankle thigh and the ankle is the
knee yeah yeah how do you say Godzilla
in Spanish is a glove yes next one fed
so bad so bad so I heard that means bad
though what are you doing why are you so
creepy kid man saw actually a fatso
could lead to lots of pencils friendship
oh I know it really big clue our first
kiss our first vessel we had Ted Sallis
beard yeah
no wait wait what's that one phrase from
the acid I'm learning it's a saying you
know like it comes out like a song are
you remembering yeah Ching bangles on
boob itself
hey hey all the way back up
sing me my little blue bet that team I
don't they teach you very formal words
like the word Tama be like a smaller
learning Cantonese yeah because it's a
way I was told to to speak in Chinese it
going they all in blue pencil and what
am i learning you're learning like
formal talking yes I don't know yeah
it's like when I would watch like the
period films of like Chinese movies
that's how they talk going bail them we
better know this one
Oh Bette oh that's out oh yeah that's
why you're my vessel all right your word
is I'm a la yeah almonds no Elma is a
girl's name it is it's like I know but
that's not somebody means alma mater be
mad elemental okay are you telling
Google there's no I don't look at your
phone because they may have your words
but what do you do I don't know I'm just
I'm thinking and when I think I get
nervous quirks of like trying to figure
things out and I just touch things that
are oh okay oh ma means forehead no am i
close no yeah
you have a soul in your body so that's
what I means in English which word is
Atma soul yeah
oh my mean soul that's enough oh that
just made that name like really pretty
didn't ya oh you think elmo is such a
grandma name you really like Elmo is
like that older generations like oh my
like another something like Eddie died
exactly yeah but now how am i sounds
pretty nice and her name is Alma like it
my turn
pinball or dream safe involved do you
see Otto nice a ping pong oh I hear what
you're saying but I can't make my mouth
I eat yeah I like sick is good yeah yeah
yeah I like to eat I like to eat people
it's got who go in it that's cute it is
in the color of Rojo is that tomato home
yeah oh you said yep go home sick quinoa
I want to eat a red apple I don't know
what what's the piece I do just that oh
yeah what point did you think it was in
that hole I start from my alpha-bits you
know like first start with aids apples
okay next one
I'm Indra Lenin I don't know
let's look at the young men that are for
directions it's a map No ah so you said
it earlier it starts with the same
letter like in Spanish in English baby
Almanac oh you just said it but you sent
it too long
Elmen no oh my god oh yeah it's a dawn
chicken soup no done what's done and
you're good with the chicken part
chicken right chicken noodles egg eggs
and chicken egg chicken how'd you know
done taught its egg part he's so smart
billboard music oh lordy and turn away
they started then yeah you want to help
us do the outro say goodbye I thank
everyone for watching okay thank you so
much for watching us try to attempt to
recognize each other's languages words I
don't know doing it better I think no I
think it's good it's so fresh in my head
through cuz I've been trying to win yeah
you've been in it you've been in the
language you know you should download an
app too there's so many apps that can
help you learn Spanish Spanish is one of
the easier languages to learn you know
what's funny as you're learning Chinese
and I'm looking at the app that you're
learning it off with I'm like oh yeah
that's a yeah you're learning company
with me you are you like you you oh you
look to you okay thanks for watching
make sure to comment down below who did
better in this challenge all right
should we call it a challenge is
I feel like a cobia time I just had a
conversation
[Music]